oy mate there's you i believe it is
wicked you coaching football you are a
legend for doing something so stupid i
mean it's
mental they're gonna murder you
this is a bit of news from the other
side of the atlantic afc richmond
announced the hiring of their new
manager american football coach ted
lasso
you're an american who's now in charge
of a football club despite possessing
very little knowledge of the game
oh i know that afc richmond is going to
give you everything they got win or lose
all ty right y'all do ties here
did you see that he must be from england
yeah well another country
yes and no how many countries are in
this country four
like it or not richmond are changing the
way we do things and from now on
that way is the lasso way hey look this
car's got an invisible steering wheel
[Music]
what you're doing is irresponsible this
club actually means something to this
town you don't think i see that every
day out there on the streets
are you kidding me i think that's what
it's all about
embracing change same thing being brave
your decision to bench jamie was a
master stroke i don't think we're
allowed to talk like that at work
for me success is not about the wins and
losses it's about helping these young
fellows to be the best versions of
themselves on and off the field
[Music]
i always figured that tea was just going
to taste like hot brown water and you
know what
i was right yeah it's horrible thank you
welcome to england
you